- So at Khan Academy,
we are striving to create personalized
mastery based learning that
transforms student's mindsets.
And within that I think
there's a three things
that make our value proposition unique.
The first is that our content
is provided free of charge
for teachers and students.
The second is that we have custom content
that's aligned to standards
in different countries.
So in Brazil, to the BNCC.
Or in the US, to the common core.
And the third is that
we are a technology that's not just
a substitute for paper and pencil,
and not such a dramatic change
that it'd be overwhelming
and you'd have to rethink
everything in your classroom,
but right in the middle
to offer an innovative change
that is not too overwhelming for teachers.
For us at Khan Academy,
mastery learning is fairly simple.
It's that the incentives,
the decisions in class
should be made based on what students
are proving they understand consistently.
And in many cases that happens in tests,
maybe not 'til the end of year tests,
but we think it should
be a full year process
building up to that point.
Really it's not like a yes or no,
are you fully mastery based
or are you not at all mastery based,
there's a spectrum of ways you can
change over your classroom
to be more mastery based.
When it comes to personalization though,
there's a few things that
are really important.
The first is that there's the
right content for students.
And that might not be the same
for all students in the class.
And we can help personalize that content,
but at the end of the
day it is the teacher
that's going to be most effective
at personalizing the
content using Khan Academy.
And second, it's self-paced.
So that if I need more
practice on a given topic,
I can have it.
I can have what we sometimes call
a functionally infinite
amount of practice.
If you're not getting it,
try again, no problem.
Well when we think about
the student mindset
that we'd all hope to have,
both for ourselves and for our students,
I think it's a student
that believes strongly
in their own potential,
and has the learning strategies
to actually understand difficult material.
And so there's a few ways we
try to enable that mindset
for learners on our platform.
The first is to remove
all barriers to learning.
So there's the content accessible
for all students at all times,
and then there's support
while you're practicing
if you get stuck.
And so there's no excuse
to not start learning,
and to not persist when you're stuck.
The focus is on you.
The second though is
processes to get unstuck,
for lack of a better word.
And so you're in the middle
of learning and you're stuck,
which is totally fine.
It's normal, happens to everyone.
But right below the practice
it's gonna say are you stuck?
Get help.
There's multiple ways
that you might need help.
You maybe need a hint, you
maybe need to watch a video,
you might need to ask your teacher.
But by going through that process,
you figure out when the right time is
to use each of those strategies.
And then the third is
through encouragement
that we give on the site,
whether you're getting
problems right or wrong,
that reinforces the message
that it's the effort that counts.
Student agency is a really popular
topic right now in education,
and I think that sometimes
there's a mistake
that it's going from no
agency to total agency.
But we really see it as a spectrum.
And on Khan Academy at a minimum,
the agency that we think is
important for students to have
would be to answer some questions like
am I on track to complete
these assignments?
What order am I gonna work on them?
And when do I know if I need help?
But as you start to show more maturity,
being able to take
control a little bit more
of the learning process,
then you can start to make
some bigger decisions.
Like what's my actual goal for this week,
or this month, or the whole school year?
What matters to me?
And when I'm done with this content,
are there other subjects
that I want to explore
on my own that aren't even required?
So the learning experience
on Khan Academy.
Well it could be different
from student to student,
I like to think of one student's
experience in particular.
So his name is Damien,
he's an 11 year old in southern
California, Los Angeles,
but I think his experience could
be typical of students in Sao Paolo,
or anywhere around the world.
But there were a few
things about his experience
that I think were really important,
and that I took away from
the ideal experience on Khan Academy.
So the first is that he had a
really clear goal for the year
that his teacher had provided
for him on Khan Academy.
And every time he logged in,
the first thing he saw was
his progress toward that big goal.
But combined with that big goal,
each day as he was practicing,
he had really detailed support,
both instructional support
through the videos and articles,
and then the practice support
through the exercises and
challenges and unit tests.
And not only that,
but he also had his
teacher there as a resource
if the instructional
resources weren't enough.
And there was this combination
of his teacher, Ms Choo
being an expert about
how to use Khan Academy,
but also Damien having
some freedom and choice
and agency to move on if he was done.
To have his own freedom to choose
what he was gonna work on that day.
So that balance between the teacher
really being able to guide
Damien towards the right material
but him also having freedom and control
over his learning process.
So you've got the big goal
and the detailed support,
and you've got the teacher as the expert,
but the student still having the freedom.
And that's I think what makes
the learning experience
distinct on Khan Academy.